[Music]
welcome to a very festive bumper episode
of we're on the Christmassy banks of the
River Thames of South Bank centres
winter festival and here's what's coming
up on the show living in la-la land why
firms are turning their backs on Silicon
Valley and heading to Los Angeles Muscle
Beach right next to that guy in Venice
Beach pumping iron is a guy in his
laptop coding our very own standards
Little Helper has been rounding up the
years must-have gadgets bad chip bad
chip anyway man's best friend just got
an upgrade watch out Rex we'll be
looking back at the year in gaming it's
been quite a ride
and later in the show I'll be speaking
to the man behind the Raspberry Pi he's
not a chef he came up with this it's a
25 pound computer that's been
revolutionizing the way children learn
to code but first and it might seem like
a bit of a jump let's go to California
here the beaches are great there
especially for tech firms getting bored
of Silicon Valley as our man in LA
Greg Milam has been finding out there
was a time when Los Angeles was well not
taken very seriously yes they made
movies they had beaches but the
important grown-up stuff was all done
300 miles north in San Francisco in
terms of the technology see LA was a bit
of a joke but things are changing in
la-la land
over 100 million people use snapchat
everyday because they feel the social
media giant snapchat doesn't just
promote itself with pretty pictures of
la cooled the company is based close to
Venice Beach the place that used to be
famous for one sort of silicon now a
growing destination for the other more
than 2 billion pounds in funding for new
firms this year alone a six-fold
increase in four years behind this
laid-back exterior serious things are
happening right next to that guy in
Venice Beach pumping iron is a guy in
his laptop coding snapchat of course is
based in Venice yeah it's I mean a side
from all the stereotypes of LA and
movies and palm trees and actors and the
beach there's a real tech scene here
Michael Schneider picked LA for his
startup an app called service which
takes complaints from angry customers
and tries to resolve them with the
company concern so why do that in LA
have you been outside today
no kidding about the weather aside la is
a fantastic place to build a tech
company first of all you're still in
California you're three to four hours
door-to-door between here and anywhere
in Silicon Valley secondly LA is much
more diverse in San Francisco a lot of
Engineers and people involved in tech
startups enjoy having a life outside of
just tech the big players realized a
while ago that silicon beach was worth a
look and it is hard to miss Google's
headquarters here there's been a steady
move south ever since and with that has
come an economic windfall in fact those
who monitor LA's tech boom say snapchat
could make 2017 very prosperous all
round they're rumored to be heading for
an IPO in March and that I peel will
value them at 25 billion dollars so at
25 billion will go to hiring people
locally will go to making a lot of folks
rich and oftentimes that money gets
recycled into reinvesting into tech
companies which could also benefit the
LA tech industry a lot and then snapchat
may acquire local companies and so
there's there's sort of an echo or
knock-on effect
from that huge infusion of cash into Los
Angeles that anyway is the hope for
silicon beach and they can look on the
bright side if it does all go wrong our
team is the elite of the elite there's a
new Baywatch movie out next year
Greg Milam Sky News Los Angeles this is
a giant Nordic gonk they're said to be
very close to Santa Claus we love
unwrapping a bit of gadgetry at
Christmas so we are Sky's technology
gonk Tom gesture to review a few tech
related stocking villas ho ho ho and a
merry dickmas one and all our gift guide
this year has a twist in that we're
going to tell all the big tech trends of
the year through varyingly affordable
gadgets first everything this year got
hacked botnets power stations
politicians Tesco Bank there's also a
massive shortage in the cybersecurity
job market in the UK so for the budding
programmer in your family take a look at
this it's called a piper craft it's a
computer you can build yourself it comes
with a screen you've got a Raspberry Pi
here as well I mean there's rather a lot
here but for an expert like me it's
comparatively easy to assemble and voila
a working computer now second on the
list tech companies have presented
Arthur with all sorts of new user
interfaces this year whether it's
snapchat spectacles apples ear pods or
the voice controlled Amazon echo so this
is the Rowley touchpad basically you can
connect it to your iPhone then use it to
my own beats that's some acid pace that
I'm gonna spend my holidays practicing
but you can also put it on learn mode
and then you get
that is much nicer inside well drones
continued to proliferate bothering
members the public and airplanes coming
in to land and now they can do more than
just fly around this small parrot drone
has a grabber attached to it for reasons
that escaped me but you can bother
people with that if you like and last
but not least the March of artificial
intelligence and automation has been a
big theme whether it's robots stealing
jobs or worries that machines will
become as smart as humans but I prefer
dogs anyway you might know chip just
then he is made by a company called
wowie in Hong Kong hey chip sit ok he's
now barking at me I'm gonna throw him a
ball tip bad chip anyway man's best
friend just got an upgrade watch out Rex
I love that dog
but 2016 wasn't just about those
must-have gift what about the inventions
the gadgets the breakthroughs that
hadn't even happened this time last year
it's jus with a roundup the world's
biggest rocket NASA fired up the space
launch system booster at a test facility
in Utah in June and this is a two for
one entry in our list the reason you can
see the blast in such detail is thanks
to a new NASA camera the first piloted
solar powered helicopter flight a group
of students at the University of
Maryland made aviation history they made
two flights about a foot off the ground
lasting around nine seconds each the
video game that took the world by storm
Pokemon go got gamers out of the house
by combining the virtual world with the
real world Europe's largest floating
power station twenty three thousand
solar panels mounted onto floats the
water keeps the equipment cool which
makes all the tech more efficient and
it's a space saver the facility is built
on a water treatment works near London
virtual reality was probably the tech
theme of the year
high-end VR headsets like oculus rift
HTC vive and PlayStation VR all came out
in 2016
in the
battle for what could be the future of
entertainment the world's first
contactless payment ring curve that's ke
RV court swipes collective I when we saw
it at London Tech week in June its
ceramic so it's waterproof and it never
needs charging and will finish as we
began in space with this ambitious
seven-year space mission NASA's
osiris-rex will try to collect dust from
a 500 meter wide asteroid to tell us
more about our solar system the mission
blasted off in September we take our
science and tech seriously at Sky News
and we've got some of the best
journalists in the business sky science
correspondent Thomas Moore and
technology correspondent Tom Cheshire
have died deep below the Atlantic toyed
with miniature trains and gone out of
this world just to bring you the best
stories
this is Sky News London how do you hear
me
I hear you laughing
[Music]
it's not a job for the squeamish one
drop of the Scorpions venom can kill a
man but now scientists are collecting
the toxins in the hope of saving lives
this is a very strange sensation I'm
used to running on a treadmill but of
course gravity would normally pull me
down this contraption simulates what it
might be like to run in zero gravity I
could work in air any orientation I like
really and it doesn't matter whether I
talk to you upside down or all the right
way up Chris Froome wouldn't be losing
any sleep computers have beaten humans
at chess and earlier this year the board
game ago they haven't had as much luck
here at the card table thing but it's
getting there
so Sky News set up a match ladies and
gentlemen it's heads up Texas Hold'em
man versus machine Facebook has been
scanning and tagging us in photos for
the last decade coral reefs are the
brain forests of the sea 25% of all
marine species live around here that's
800,000 and all and that is why it
caused such a good indicator of help
putting more systems online office
hackers more things to attack this hike
up here has legs and it can balance you
can even give it a little shove sorry
and they'll stay on its own two feet
these are 80s a chip time mosquitoes the
species spreading the Zika virus now
these are male so they shouldn't bite me
but no threat to me
[Music]
this might have to be limited and how
many shots we can get that's it for part
1 of our very festive bumper episode of
swipe here's something to keep you
thinking in the break what sex products
was on fire this year literally coming
up in a moment stay with us
[Music]
welcome back to our swipe a bumper
Christmas special in a moment we'll be
looking back at some of the year's
biggest moments in gaming so before the
break I asked you what tech product was
on fire this year and the answer you
guessed it Samsung's Galaxy Note seven
now this is the Raspberry Pi it's become
a genuine British tech success for the
way it's been helping children learn
computer science I went to meet the
company's founder Evan Upton first chats
about the tech industry is CBE and we
even touched on rockstars but I began by
asking him what his favorite moment of
the year had been I think my favorite
moment in 2016 was launching raspberry
pi 3 which we did on the 29th of
February 4th birthday how would you
explain raspberry pi to somebody who'd
been living on another planet for the
past few years a raspberry pi is a
credit card sized little bit of printed
circuit board a little green bit of
printed circuit board you plug it into
your television you plug a mouse and a
keyboard into it and plug your mobile
phone power charger into it to give it a
little bit of juice and then it's a
regular PC the pi is known for being
small it's come a long way since Evans
early model that's the Raspberry Pi from
2006 we're basically looking at the
inside of a computer right yeah that's
right and now you shrunk that right down
that's 2016 Raspberry Pi so 10 years
later this is something like a thousand
times as powerful as that it costs the
same as it's still a 25-pound computer
how big has Raspberry Pi become now
since you first launched we thought if
we could sell 10,000 raspberry pies over
the lifetime of the product that would
be fantastic in September this year we
celebrated our tenth millionth the
Raspberry Pi foundation is a charity and
runs a network of code clubs in the UK
what do you think is the biggest problem
in Britain right now with computing for
me the biggest problem in computing in
the UK right now is the lack of
government investment in teacher
training so wonderful things have
happened over the last few years in
terms of our curriculum we've gone from
having a curriculum that teaches you
have a type you know three or four years
ago to a curriculum which is really
robust and really rigorous and has
really good computer science concepts
and unfortunately that's been a
fantastic achievement for the government
unfortunately it hasn't been matched by
the scale of investment in teacher
training now looking back on 2016 as a
whole in the tech sector
what do you thought it's been a good
year for tech I mean we've had some ups
and downs you know we've had some expire
exploding phones we've had some
personally I'm maybe I'm a little
disappointed by the direction that some
of the surveillance stuff is taking the
investigative powers Act that's gone
through if you look at the list of
agencies who are able to go look at your
go look at your metadata it's absolutely
enormous and so there's this concern
that we're kind of drifting you know
some of the some of the openness of the
internet maybe drifting away some of the
some people would argue if you've got
nothing to hide I think it's
disappointing if the burden of proof is
in that direction and you've certainly
had some ups this year a CBE there's a
lovely bit of recognition for for the
people in the organisation and also hope
for the community they 800 or 8,000
people out there in the community who
were doing awesome stuff with the
Raspberry Pi what are you expecting to
see in 2017 in tech I'd like to see
Tesla making good progress towards to us
getting the model 3 out the door would
you ever make a move into transport I
think it's one of those things that
involves a vast to just requires vast
vast vast amounts of money it's one of
the most exciting things that happen
that's happening in tech you kind of
wonder if in 20 years time we'll be
looking back on this era of petrol power
to petrol powered cars as being sort of
like we now look back on the world kind
of world of horse-drawn carts so there's
one of the most exciting things but I
don't have a spare billion dollars to go
and do it's almost to give me a billion
dollars I will happily go and build an
electric cars we often hear people say
that tech stars are the new rock stars
so which rock star do you think you're
most like and why you get these guys
like like Don Henley who are they're
just good at they good at something and
they end up being the frontman because
there was just a particular thing they
were good at and that's what's that's
what I'd like to be I'd like to be
somebody who's just good at engineering
the drama is always in charge they
really
that's everyone else's people yellow
let's say people always people always
tell jokes about the drama but without
the drama it's not really a boundary
it's been a huge year for gaming from
the rise of VR to surprise game
announcement there have been so many
memorable moments so we assembled a top
team of reviewers to give us their pick
of the bunch 2016 it has been a huge
year for Triple A games which are kinda
like the blockbuster titles of the games
industry first up we had this game could
uncharted 4 which is the final
installment in Nathan Drake's bombastic
crazy adventure series those who prove
worthy and a game that just oozes the
narrative story driven game you play and
gorgeous and a bombastic action
sequences after that we had a game
called Dishonored 2 which is a stealth
driven game where you play as an
assassin for Corvo or his daughter emily
kaldwin there's a lot of choices that
you have to make a lot of moral
decisions but it's really the gameplay
design where this really stands out is
but some of this gorgeous levels I've
seen in two decades of playing games
lust but no Easley's is a game called
overwatch which is a multiplayer shooter
but it's a shooter with a difference
it's a shooter that really requires to
play and strategy and working with other
people more so than any other and it
also has these characters that from a
whole range of countries a whole range
of ethnicity the whole range of
sexualities
I think that's is brilliant there has
been a lot of Triple A games come out
this year but for me the best of
happening story wise is really coming
out of independent Studios and two games
would really really set out for me
inside and Firewatch now an inside it
manages to tell this amazing story light
without a single line of dialogue or
narration and you really wouldn't catch
like a quality Wii game doing that
everything is told it inside through
like these little background things that
you see and little clues that you pick
up on and basically done through two
buttons which for me is such an amazing
way of telling like a really really
chilling storyline
I still haven't stopped thinking about
it the other game is Firewatch where you
play a character who doesn't shut up
heywhat it just they wrecked the place
through my typewriter on the window he
talks a lot and he's taken a job a
really isolated job in the middle of
nowhere just losing my mind
watching out for fires in this forest
and you're never quite sure what's going
on if you try to unravel a mystery or
how much you can actually trust the guy
who you're playing but I just think
inside a fire watch for me are doing
things with story but the Triple A games
I am coming close to 2016 hasn't just
been about the games themselves it's
also been massive for hardware after
decades of speculation we finally have
not one not two but three real working
VR headsets in the shape of the oculus
rift the HTC vive and the PlayStation VR
though early sales for promising with
Sony in particular unable to have supply
to meet demand
I think we've yet to see the killer app
that will make these have staying power
also on the hardware front Sony released
a souped up version of its ps4 the ps4
pro that source sales tripled in the
first week in the UK Microsoft is gonna
replicate this next year with the Xbox
one Scorpio and finally after lots of
speculation Nintendo revealed its new
console it's a console tablet hybrid
called the Nintendo switch more details
on that will be coming in January there
have been some really incredible
announcements to come out of 2016 so
first of all Red Dead Redemption 2
because if you think West world was the
thing that made Cowboys cool again nope
it was Rockstar Games back in 2010 with
Red Dead Redemption we don't really know
much about the sequel but if it's
anywhere near as good as the first game
then we are gonna be in for a treat
that's coming out next year there's also
going to be the Last of Us part 2
so it took the Panic classic post
pandemic tale and crafted a really
emotional story that really sticks with
you so they've announced that there's
gonna be a sequel to finally death
stranding so Hideo Kojima a famed game
designer who worked on Metal Gear Solid
for like upwards of 20 years now but now
he's been a free and he's making his
first game outside of Konami he's got
the Guillermo del Toro
he has Norman Reedus Mads Mikkelsen he's
got this all-star cast it's gonna be
crazy I'm really excited to see
what that's gonna be like and these are
all gonna be coming out next year we're
nearly at the end of our swipe festive
special we've looked back on the year in
tech but what we really need to do now
is look back on the year in swipe
there's a mini mashup of some of our
2016 tech adventures the wireframe model
shows my movement and then layers are
added so the designers can turn me into
any character they want maybe not the
scariest or hopefully the finished
product is a bit more fearsome than I am
one of the benefits of this setup is its
flexibility the virtual cabin can be
easily inflated and deflated so it can
be packed up and move between bases just
how much of an advantage can I bikes
like this one bring you firstly they
come with integrated motive to those who
may need a little pedal assist the car
isn't for sale yet BAC still durability
testing the prototype and you could say
I got the help with that in my own way
you've heard the expression he's off in
his own little world well I'm taking
that to new extremes thanks to virtual
reality I'm quite literally the king of
my own little castle now this is
something anyone can have a go at as I'm
cycling the movements I'm making are
powering the fridge behind me NASA is
planning on sending humans to an
asteroid by 2025 an engineer's here at
Airbus are among those working with
scientists around the world to make
those difficult missions possible your
character isn't neuron controlling a
computer with the power of my mind do
you see a cursor or the light here this
wearable neuro technology allows me to
play these games without moving it's
basically a big tube of cold with
temperatures as low as minus 40 degrees
[Music]
if you want to watch any of those
episodes in full you can see all our
shows on demand in the usual places
now that brings us to the end of our
swipe festive special we'll be back in
the New Year hope you can join us then
bye-bye
you
[Music]